you
okay for those joining us we are talking
about GPU support and how to show which
functionality has default GPU support in
Wolff language so I guess a net train
has a target device option is that
correct that's great oh look look what
just happened there isn't this supposed
to have separators sorry this is a
question for Sushma I think more than
anybody else yeah it is supposed to have
separators I will to put that and it's
also I think the line spacing is a
little bit generous here maybe maybe not
maybe that isn't so bad but anyway okay
um okay so in that train we have a
target device option so now I supposedly
have this machine that I'm connected to
with a remote kernel which actually has
a GPU that works as opposed to my
desktop Mac that doesn't um and so boy
this oh I see
so let's see so if I say this
I mean I said this example didn't have a
a roar n equals but anyway um
okay so here we're going to build that
a fine
now what are you doing here so you're
saying this is gonna train the thing
great
lovely what's that
that's shouldn't happen what's happening
I see
I wanna this is the bug honey that's
what what GPU is this I don't know you
told me how to find that out that's one
of the questions here yeah it's I mean
the it's a Nvidia 1080 ok so let me just
find out okay so this is my challenge
how do I find that out I've got my Linux
machine how do I ask it what can these
are ways with CUDA link so you can do
could I think okay what is this by the
way the child process reports an X get
CP jet GPU count has failed blah blah
blah okay so what should I do here and
just for him join us by the way yes okay
um okay so now what do I do I have to
load CUDA link is that correct yes and
then you do CUDA information open-close
open-close this might download something
large
downloading it's downloading the whole
Nvidia CUDA toolkit okay so something we
haven't done yet which we need to do
post 12 for us to basically share the
CUDA toolkit between neural networks who
could link so that it's not replicated
like this okay the tree has it it's
already shipped so we really include
this in the builds and we could avoid
this whole town loading process but that
requires a quad coordination that we
haven't done yet okay
okay I'm quite sure that this is not
going to work because we haven't
released the
and Radiator toolkit park lights for
Linux and version 12 okay are they ready
or they are they far away for Windows it
is ready and for Linux I just have to
test but beyond that yard I just haven't
gotten to testing it okay so in May 11 3
everything should be ok but all this new
stuff might not work ok ok fair enough
but so in a first approximation so first
thing is that in system information for
example we currently don't have anything
about GPUs that true I think that's not
quite true
ok well we'll find out in a moment
well fronting and has its own way of
figuring that out but maybe it depends
on crude oil and coal
you could try started a second yeah
exactly
take a notebook with the drawn kernel
and say something like system
information I'm sure I mean if I just
say that over here um this is just a
kernel on my local machine so if I say
system information here
got this is really slow okay
so machine here
well okay system-specific I don't know
what I mean other than that's lovely I
didn't even know we had that stuff but
um yeah try devices exactly
what's so what where would this normally
be
it would it be under devices normally I
actually don't know okay
okay well okay so that has to be looked
at alright so then the next question is
what so one of the things we wanted so
which functions that things like speech
recognizer um
the UM somebody's commenting on the
livestream um
you
the well let's try find out whether this
particular let's just see whether this
code even works and let's just see
whether the code works so let's just see
what happens so this is just running on
my local machine where I don't believe
I'm able to use the GPU I don't even
know if it has a GPU does a MacPro have
a GPU but I believe it's not going to
work
yeah you should get a nice error if you
don't it's a bug yeah
minor thing for Sushma to report I have
no idea whether that's a - greater than
sign rather than a rule and that output
um it'd be nice of this at a failure box
rather than just a dollar fail but
anyway okay minor issue okay so now if
you're saying if I change the target
device to CPU then I should just get a
happy training process going on right
albeit slower okay so let me just
understand what functions so it's things
like speech recognizer that under the
hood could use a GPU is that correct
yes sir I think that was built with your
networks can use GPUs okay but the
question is we need to tell people so it
won't use GPUs by default because you
don't know what else is going on on the
GPU on your machine it's not the reason
though it's you don't want to just
preemptively say sure just go ahead and
use the GPU exactly so it's dangerous
for us to do that and there's no
framework in the world where it's like
use a GPU if nothing else has grabbed
the GPU or how does GPU how does okay
let me ask a naive question how does
shadowing work for GPUs or doesn't it
it's just amazing in the computer
industry you know I mean these things
were you know back in the day they used
to be this one sort of attached Co
processor that does this one special
thing and then you know gradually it
gets incorporated into the CPU and gets
sort of scheduled by the operating
system I have to say I thought GPUs
would go that way and wouldn't survive
as standalone objects but I was wrong
but but how do you schedule GPU
operations
you
um guys fight by scheduling you mean
well I mean I you've got two processes
that are both trying to use the GPU what
happens
what what what two processes are you
referring to for example let's say I had
two Wolfram language curls right that
we're both doing this operation and both
said I want the GPU what happens all
right I mean like the Nvidia drivers
will naturally take care of that that we
don't need to worry about that what does
it do what does it do just shares them
well but how does it load memory I mean
so it must have a scheduler so it must
know to load the thing do it do its
thing
unload it to the next thing and so on
that's the job of the library is like
Amex nice okay guys guys if you've been
running if this thing's gonna run for
five minutes
of GPU time right and you're trying to
run another thing for five minutes to
GPU time when does it get interrupted
let's not have to us that's the
operating system does that so like if
Firefox decides that it needs the GPU to
you know like render some video that's
not up to us to interrupt it you can't
we can't control that that is up to the
operating system to adjudicate that okay
but I mean that's normally what a
scheduler would do right but but so by
the way this is seem to do nothing
um right as I said it won't work in 12
we can probably have to fire up eleven
three okay hey Roger then then how do I
get an 11 it'll be working on that
remote machine
oh I instead just go and ssh into that
machine and just try come online thing I
can play see it in the command line or
will it do something fancy oh great
I need a raw IP address please can you
piss it's not India enough what's that
can you pissed us that error message as
well that internal lust internal failure
that's gonna be very very useful for us
do something here yeah let whole block
well why don't I just give you I mean
okay fine we could be modern and use the
chat framework and I could just send
this to you like this um that's too
modern for you guys um here I'll send
you the box structure okay let me ask
you another question for QA what is
their situation with testing all the
stuff because there obviously many GPU
configurations if I have any say that is
pretty bad currently so the first
problem is we don't have enough hardware
to test it okay there are many different
configurations so we you know we'll
never have all that Hardware right and
so what we do is one of the reasons why
Amex net and CUDA make are so big is
that we put in all the flags for
different compute capabilities that are
supported by the GPU and therefore it is
so big so we just assumed that we have
done the right thing and we send it out
in the world and that user tell us okay
hey Roger how do I get I need to do aids
nate's
yeah but how do I get to eleven three
because this is right how do I get to
eleven three yeah sending that to you
it's in user local or from well they
just send me at the link place some some
of them either thing oh you can you just
send me the the path please yeah I don't
seem to be getting anything here
you send me the path please yeah it
didn't like send it by email if you need
to send it by any method you need yeah I
just took any of the quotes around that
but just remove the quotes
why is it in the Mathematica directory
well there's a desktop directory titter
okay fine what a woods the name of the
executable what's the name of the
executable yeah Wolfram like that that
correct or want like I'm on different
screens right now it's lowercase W okay
there's eleven three okay so needs CUDA
link okay oh come on okay we actually
okay so I figured out so ym excellent
well why this wasn't working in twelve
so we just want catching this error
properly and reporting properly but
basically the problem is that the driver
version is told so this is driver for
for CUDA is too old or what okay so can
we force update okay so so let me just
understand this is in Linux right so I
don't even remember how you get machine
information and that's what's it called
the gosh what is the Linux command to
get machine information what kind of
information you want there's like an LS
PCI to list this is in my is the
issuance okay okay so magnificent but
but what what should what is it Nvidia
says Nvidia and then - SMI space - SMI
oh no no space - us and why okay so
find the stalls well so why don't I
install it I mean is that is that the
and how did it no I don't understand how
it knew to to tell me that it could be
installed when it wasn't installing it
so okay so few things so this this is
this can be an involved process to
install this this is probably and also
there's there's a silly thing with 1/2
which is that it doesn't have the most
the latest drivers so there's a special
way of getting them okay hold on
so this is saying do you want to
continue what is all this horrific stuff
that's happening okay this seems so
modern reminds me of a boot sequence
back in the early eighties you don't
usually see these put sequences anymore
um stolen video from apt it will break
everything so Ethan on a live stream oh
dear this is a dangerous you playing a
dangerous game here well this is a this
is not my primary machine so this is a
this is a a secondary machine if I don't
know it's some it's my kind of play like
machine um okay but Nick is so what I'm
trying to do is I'm trying to get some
indication of you know what what I would
get that there's a way of finding out
what the CPU version is in the lux and
so on there's a that we use that for
machine identification I just don't
remember what the name of the command is
okay
so let's try this same thing Nvidia
- SMI is that correct yeah oh for
goodness sake this is it's a nightmare
getting I'm not impressed but this is
you know it's notorious that it's
notoriously hard to get it working on
Linux well where is it not hard to get
it working you told me Mac doesn't work
at all so is this like a Windows only
deal so Windows is the main gaming
platform so it is the easiest to install
Windows for sure hey Roger my yeah I
could can I get to my Windows machine
from here easily I mean - like a remote
colonel or something like that or yes no
is it configured to have remote kernels
no so i have to like i wasn't KVM switch
and things which is not going to be
useful for everybody else right I mean I
could run zoom on the windows side of
the KVM yeah it's too too complicated
okay so we're doing really horribly here
um yeah and this is completely out of
control like the user really has to you
know get this working themselves and do
we have any way of checking whether it's
working before we start generating giant
pink error messages sure so that that's
just a bug like we have a check that's
normally seized with the version or
what's the driver version us and we give
a report we say we require driver
version whatever and we even give a link
to a website we can download the driver
and all the sort of thing yeah it's just
somehow wasn't caught in this error
message so I'm just not sure why right
so so Ethan our live stream is saying
our own system information should do
this we absolutely agree but we can't do
it unless we can even get the data I
mean in other words so right now we're
is I'm you know to ask a very basic
question is is the GPU a slash dev slash
something or other what
the GPU on in terms of Bullock's
operating system by him I have no idea
sorry do we have somebody around who
would know
George on our livestream is saying that
he had a lot of trouble getting this to
work even when Apple had nvidia gpus and
he was hoping that our company would do
the heavy lifting to make all this stuff
work great thanks okay okay but back to
okay so let's see I wonder if there's
anybody we could pull into this meeting
who would know this do we know anybody
in the systems group who would know this
that's a deafening silence let's see if
we can reach Warren
you can ask her if he knows anything
about okay so we're doing absolutely
horribly here so let's try to understand
the original goal here was to figure out
okay so for example um Sebastian if I
look at your machine will it run with
target device arrow GPU yeah sure okay
so these these commands will run in a
machine
so why don't you go ahead and share your
screen and just show us the results of
these things that make sense okay so I'm
gonna uncheck can you share yes my skin
I do we see a bunch of Stack Overflow
stuff yes it's okay so we can really
just have a quick look at the target
device no I want to see your CUDA I want
to see you load okay with this is kind
of okay yeah let's try it try it try it
try try it okay am I gonna see anything
different in the in the display here
that says it's GPU in I will not
well it says but it says coma GP user
accepts it yes okay so this works okay
now let's see cooler information
connection as I do what why is that
having okay
Fahim you have a version of this that's
running so this is we have other options
if you ready once no well I know for him
do you have a version that's running I
haven't even I don't know but I can try
I'll let you know if it works okay
okay okay let's go back so someone here
I don't know how to how to refer to
people on a live stream and they don't
have plausible first names designed by
the UM suggests a command let me see
what this does
who knows what this command does pseudo
l sh w what is l sh w Oh list hardware
that's interesting well that's more
modern than I've ever seen fascinating I
don't remember that that didn't that
wasn't there back when I Steven yeah is
working on mine at least we take you
gifts true so I'm hopeful that it will
work so what do you want me to do okay
hold on I want you to run cooter
information but first of all I'm looking
at this okay so what does this mean no
that's a display what is this
that doesn't seem to be anything to do
with what is this I'm I'm so confused
this thing is behaving like a VGA
oh my gosh and how can the clock be 33
megahertz I thought these things were
blindingly fast
okay who understands what this is
talking about here I mean the clock
speeds always gonna be a lot slower than
CPUs it's just a lot of them but 64-bit
width it says which is not that much
oh my gosh
sworn hi okay we are trying to figure
out about machine configurations with
GPUs maybe you know about this maybe you
don't um how do you find out you're
sitting looking at a Linux machine you
want to know how is its GPU configured
or even if it has one I mean you're
you're probably going to do LS PCI would
give you things connected to the PCI bus
which would give you very basic
information probably okay I just did
that on my machine so I don't even see
anything here that is um oh I see audio
device Nvidia blah blah blah but I
honestly one is video credible there we
go what does that mean what why does it
say VGA compatible controller that means
VGA like the display drive this play
standard yeah I think this is just Linux
or whoever wrote LS PCI just being a
little bit conservative in how they're
displaying names there to say that oh
hey this is just a video controller or
you know the video display device not
the fact that it's this is some device
or this display link or whatever does
this thing show up in /dev or is it not
of that type I don't actually think that
shows up well in theory anything should
show up at /dev but I don't think it's
something that you can easily get at
probably the easiest way to control it
would be to load the appropriate drivers
for Nvidia and they probably have a
proprietary binary that will tell you
all kinds of things about that device
the the output on your screen that you
had earlier if you scroll just a tiny
bit where you were at right there that's
telling you that the driver
Nouveau Nouveau is an open source
basically reverse-engineered driver for
nvidia controllers ati has an equivalent
as well
that the Linux community has is sort of
put together although they're their
driver sets on Linux are actually from
the open-source side a lot of it better
now because of a TI's sort of commitment
to help there but anyway Nouveau is is
the is the open-source
reverse engineer driver you'll get
probably much better both performance
and information by is loading the closed
binary I'm not sure if what machine you
have here if this is a Linux box what
kind of distribution you have it's the
long spokes what do I have on I have
Ubuntu what is it I believe there's some
nice ish way in a boot too although I
don't have it around I'm gonna do for
over a decade so I can't really tell you
off the top of my head to just go ahead
and download that automatically through
the Bluetooth repositories alternatively
you could go out to video comm download
the driver probably as a Deb package
which would work with the bun to and and
loaded in that way which would would
unfortunately probably maybe the more
modern ones they have some kind of
automatic kernel module thing but it
used to compile a kernel module for the
driver which is essentially what the the
nouveau stuff is it's just built into
the Linux kernel because for the longest
time NVIDIA well even now video doesn't
provide basically getting help for the
open source community
in that manner they just give you their
close binaries and say hey if you want
this to work like should you should use
these if not then okay let me just try
to understand I mean like for example
knowing so MX net is then supporting
directly who is doing things like
deciding how big the GPUs memory is
deciding how big the you know blobs of
stuff he put in the GPU are all that
kind of stuff who's doing that how is
that working so we have control over
some of its and MX net is obviously the
one that uh negates the memory okay do
we know how much memory we have to
allocate how does it know how much
memory to allocate it tries so it will
it has it has some plan so it says okay
this is how much memory we've you know
we try allocate things and you know so
the student answers it nxn has two
different kinds of allocation modes so
one is that it can have you know it just
sees the plan for the the network and I
can say we need this amount of memory
for that but there's parts of the
network especially for NVIDIA zone
primitives that will run a little bits
and they'll test themselves out on that
particular GPU and I'll decide how much
memory they want okay so how many of our
layer primitives are GPU enabled through
the Nvidia essentially driver for their
GPU all of them all of them okay
interesting okay and so so all of so if
we simply run an evaluation network
through and we say so is it the case
that a random layer has a target device
option every layer has it talking to my
selection did you explicitly document
that I mean if I say like element wise
layer for example or something trivial
is that is that gonna say in its
documentation here there's not
particularly interesting but it is it's
supported why do you say it isn't
interesting I mean okay let me ask a
different question what um I'll give you
the answer very quickly before it's not
interesting so fillet is that
so basically sin dividual is if you
don't have much computation that's
happening on the GPU then the overhead
of transferring or shuttling data
between GPU and CPU is basically not
worth it here so with it okay this yeah
i rectified linear units
you know we vastly faster on CPU
well just doing it once right just once
okay
so what is the speed-up that we expect I
mean like it like if you run right now
on your GPU can we see if you run it
when your GPU can can we see some
timings relative to CPU just for my
information so okay can you share and do
that yes I can do that also what is the
story with OpenCL on the Mac is that is
that's still alive or what happened to
it
I mean Mac when Apple's deprecated at
any support for conceal they think it's
a dead format and they've so what is
that plan for for GPU support so they're
they've got something called metal yeah
okay but how does that okay but but
bottom line for MX net since you know
you know Apple has been a contributor to
MX net one would think that it should
run on their hardware I mean they use it
for research purposes they don't care
about shipping at every machine they
have a very very difference yeah I mean
they have a very very optimized network
evaluator the ship with Apple devices
and we are we able to use that not yet
so what will be involved in a fusing
that the simplest approach is basically
unk's chunks as a converter to apples
formats so once you in the hunks
ecosystem there's all kinds of nice
adapters for the other formats okay so
let's do this
and then then okay so this is like for
the Nets that's about a thousand six
hundred inputs per second okay and if we
do this GPU and this is a very terrible
GPU it's a laptop GPU
what's that preparing data for input
port what does that mean okay so that's
about four times three times something
like that
yeah for a laptop GPU that's kind of
what you'll get for a crappy laptop GPU
like this one that's 5 years old but if
you yeah I mean if you have a
top-of-the-line GPU it's a very
different ballgame ok but so ok at first
point is like how does a person you know
we don't have a system information way
right now for people to even figure out
if they have a GPU right that's Christ I
mean that's kind of upsetting at some
level I mean if I run system information
on this machine
um so hopefully there we go it's nice ok
so it's going to give me a bunch of
information about the Machine it's going
to give me devices information that
devices information I don't even know
where the device information is coming
from but that's not telling me anything
about GPUs would you expect it to
so it's a tricky question because the
way they would do it is either get CUDA
link and then display it that's one way
of doing it but but I was getting raw
information from from I mean here I was
getting some like for example even
running this LS PCI thing is giving me
some idea that I have a GPU what's the
most robust way in by making a system
call on Linux operating system to find
out if you have a GPU
you
so somebody was suggesting here the this
just catting I mean if we simply import
/proc / cpu info actually we can just
read it as a string right okay and does
this have anything about well let's find
out if it has the word GPU in it um
definitely because it's about the CPU
only right that's just telling you what
feature set and speed and gasses all
things about the CPUs hmm okay okay so
warren do you have an answer to this
question what's the best way to find out
if you have a GPU my experience here
would definitely not be a super valid I
mean most my user just as an end user on
a desktop machine like I said loading up
a driver and I've never done anything
with you as a computable device like you
know Bitcoin mining or anything like
that so I'm not okay so so right now for
our users we have no plausible way
beyond telling them some complicated
chain of things involving downloading
drivers to even find out if they have a
GPU at first statement so I open up your
computer and figure out whether that
chip is there
I have a quick question um the the
graphics subsystem the OpenGL there's a
second one there on top of the one you
expanded does that one that's an ATI
that seems to be another 80 I know
that's because I have two displays no no
what am I talking about I have no idea
why why this machine which is a headless
machine I believe has two graphics
subsystems in it let's nurse Mac yeah
how can it be running on well are the
devices from the front end because it's
Apple thunderballs oh I see I see
machine here that's again very very
confusing so is this running okay this
is the kernel right and that's running
on Upsilon mm-hmm but you're telling me
that other that everything else here
okay so front end is obviously the local
machine um
[Music]
okay and I don't know what the machine
machine means what does that mean I
wonder okay that branches into a
separate issue which was which we should
address with the core software
engineering folk about what system
information is doing with remote kernels
which looks kind of not so to me here
like which machine is this talking about
do what do we know
oh but what I was gonna suggest there as
far as the GPU stuff is whatever calls
they're making on the front end to get
that information for OpenGL would likely
be run on whatever assume you're
connecting to a remote kernel here's
what you're talking about could
potentially be RAM but what are those
calls
I see so you're pointing out that
whatever this device thing is here and
the thing I'm a little
confused by is how do I run system
information I see if I run system
information over here yeah look look
look look I can do this if I just do
this if I run it just absolutely raw
where there's no front-end
ok then I will get information here that
contains that should contain a lot of
stuff um but in particular it will
contain devices so let's take a look
system information of devices running on
the headless machine
oh boy really that's weird so if I say
Network here
Wow okay why would it say missing not
active so that because Linux won't give
me this information
I don't again don't know the answers to
that question
okay okay well so um so do animations I
think very quickly just slightly
orthogonal to this thing which is that a
longer term solution that would be very
nice for users is some sort of clouds
support so that you can you know train
it on some fog machine that has all the
setup done for you sure well because the
question is is that really what people
want people want to be able to do it on
the local machines but it's obviously a
big pain now do we have workflows about
GPUs is that do we already have
workflows documenting things about GPUs
we don't
it's an our to do list for twelve okay
so we have no such so what so this whole
you know horror story that we've just
been going through trying to get my GPU
configured there is supposed to be a
workflow that says what to do with that
that the idea that's we haven't even
discussed that sort of thing because
it's so potentially complicated there is
a tutorial for CUDA link and it does go
through and deep details above so it's
it's it's not completely not there it's
just a bit outdated is what I'd say okay
so another question is on this page here
our compatibility page do we have okay
GPU architectures but we're talking
there about the heck are we talking
about so that seems to be your tutorial
so right
but as I say right now it is not it's
definitely not up to date how are we
going to keep this up to date okay so
okay so this is what cooter information
if it worked would give it does work on
Windows but you don't have them do this
well not not here right now okay but so
so this is um okay
what is the one mean that that's one of
the GPUs yes
device count
what do you mean it's a device count
it's not good you can have multiple
cards but then each each card is named
and that's its name yeah sorry
no no I mean but that's the name of the
that's the name of the type of device
but but if you were to decide to send a
neuron that job to a particular GPU you
would name the GPU you would say send it
to GPU number three or something is that
right yeah for next train for example we
supporting that in 12 that syntax so how
does that work so that an in target
device are you saying that target device
has a as a name for so the way we're
doing it right now is that's what an
earth is this okay target device GPU
comma n lovely the number of GPUs
available on your computer and what is
this now so this is what we build MX
nets against we ensure this
compatibility of the specific views and
what is the capability
23.7 what does all that mean it's just
basically like a generation of GPUs so
there's a whole bunch of GPUs that fall
into one generation okay and but these
are and these are like in years so
basically like the bottom ones are the
most recent ones so cheering is the
latest one okay they're getting more
recent I mean look at that babe oh no
that their history is kind of funky here
um okay okay but but so alright so look
the original topic here is well alright
the original topic was how to tell
people which functions are GPU enabled
and what by the way that the compiler
our compiler does not how far away is
our compiler from supporting you know
compilation to anything that can be
there used on GPU that's certainly a
question for the compiler group but the
discussions we had with them about this
particular topic a few months ago was
that they said they were close to having
so once that's the case you'll be able
to take a Wolfram language function you
will then compile it I mean if I just
say function compile of let's say um I
don't know what I say you know type 2 X
integer 64 or something I want to say oh
that's not what I want there hex I wish
we had some examples on those pages x
squared is that right so that's gonna
give me okay so then I say
how do i how do I get some how to
actually see the LLVM code here
um function compiled export string of
this okay
there's okay so the claim would be so
what will be the workflow for making
this so let's say I have this compiled
function and then I want to run this on
a GPU what will I actually do
so there's a I think the targets a
compilation target or something there is
a calculation target that's correct yeah
I think that the way that would work is
the compilation well that's all well and
good so I can get GPU code out I mean
just like right now I think I can get a
target
let's see compilation target here we
don't seem to sushma bug bug bug we
don't have um we don't seem to have the
auto completion compilation target so
the compilation target here
for compile
the heck is this that's something yet
different again
that's the old compiler that's the old
compiler and that's generating explicit
C code from the old compiler but okay
let's imagine that I successfully
generated code here and I don't
understand and Sushma there's something
you should ask compiler folk what the
relationship is is a compilation target
and the new compiler stuff but let's say
I have GPU code here what do I do with
it
how do i how do I actually run it on
anything so for example lemon let me
show you the example of something fairly
different which is the recent um
microcontroller stuff right because
there
what has to happen is there's this thing
microcontroller embed code which
actually pushes the code to the
microcontroller
is that what I just don't know I don't
know what it looks like I don't know
what the operating system interface does
GPU is supposed to look like
oh it's if you have a function that is a
bunch of GPU code and you want to simply
run it and call it with certain
arguments how does that work what do we
think the the top-level interface to
that should be
so I think CUDA link has a has something
exactly like this where you can give it
kuda could and it will create a function
america function from it so I think it's
called CUDA function load okay so hey
maybe you can speak to that
alright yeah there is good a function
therefore you open documentation for it
you should have examples okay so that is
analogous to thief embed code the
Arduino embed code
what the heck does this do so this loads
it into my GPU is that correct and then
does it have an entry point or something
for so we have something called C
compiler driver and we have an VC C
compiler and that's how we do this
that's how we compile to see okay I'm
sorry
so that again I mean I'm a little
confused here so I've got a piece of
code here that's a piece of law what is
that is that C or something what did I
say I see you could Darcy you file okay
okay the CUDA is like a weird dialect
dialect of C okay so like like an
Arduino except not an Arduino so to
speak I mean just another weird I like
to see okay fine okay so CUDA function
load does what it takes it says I'm
going to set up a function called add to
that's its type signature is that right
yes
what's the 256 it's pretty one of the
launch settings which is launch settings
so there's like what kinds of things
like parameters for I could block sizes
and various other things if I you know
run this on the GPU okay okay but anyway
so we've got this thing and this defines
so then I don't really understand what's
actually put on the GPU I mean the the
the code okay a GPU is sitting there and
does it have a bunch of code loaded on
it and it has entry points where you
call a particular function and the GPU
that works the way this would work is
that's CUDA link and MXN link actually
there's they ship something called the
Nvidia runtime compiler so at runtime
you can just give it a piece of code and
it will just compile it at runtime and
you can start using it on the GPU I
understand that but but why is it giving
a name here
that suggests that on the GPU I mean
it's like like in you know you yes you I
mean it used to be the case back in the
day you know when I first used a
computer it had one program and you just
started at a particular you know program
counter location except it was called a
sequence control register back where I
came from the um and you would go to
that location and start running and then
the idea that you could have multiple
programs and you would I mean does it
have more than one program or are you
always just loading one program into it
and running it
if you need if you why do you need this
name if there isn't more than one
program so in the C program you can see
so you can define in C multiple programs
how the delegation happens to the GPU
how much you know goes in the memory or
not same time but that global thing that
underscore underscore global means that
this is a CUDA kernel function and that
can be called by the GPU I don't know
exactly know what what point it's in the
memory or not of the GPU
okay so then CUDA fun here is so this is
returning this object with some
mysterious internal state there is some
kind of pointer to the GPU function that
you bring a man call here okay I think I
get it so this will be the same thing as
let's see um alright I think I
understand okay so
okay so the roadmap going forward is the
compiler will eventually generate GPU
code probably fairly soon generate GPU
code and there will be a similar
function for loading that now the GPU
code that this compiler is generating is
this gonna work the old vm based GPU
code is that going to work on sort of
all GPUs or is it going to again be just
this particular sort of stack of NVIDIA
GPUs on windows or something
anybody know
not like genital okay
all right fine okay so look our original
question was um
yeah which indeed someone ally on the
livestream asks the exact question that
was the original source of this meeting
is how to signal which functions
actually can use the GPU our GPU enabled
and what you're basically telling me is
for example the documentation page for
net train could have a little flag that
says I'm GPU enabled however it's kind
of not as simple a story as that because
um you know it's a fairly specific type
of GPU etc etc right that's true and
also it's you know yeah exactly like
Kudo it's OpenCL so it's complicated so
it would have to be something that could
enable door who knows what's a GPU well
even correct is it the case that any go
good
oh so all the stuff with CUDA should
work and so not any GPU would be
supported
I don't know about Emmett smart but
obviously the crudest off so let me
understand something else when we get
onyx export right there is it going to
look like you get a network and you have
run training in our system and then you
literally say export of the network
comma onyx and it will generate just a
file is that what onyx is is just files
or is it something else just a file
okay so fundamentally I mean right now
if I say you know if I just said net
model the net or something here I would
have a I keep on running now on this
weird Linux machine so just to be exotic
here um and also see if it actually
works okay so you're saying right now is
there any export that I can do right now
for this you can export to an X Nancy so
if I say exports during this thing to MX
net just export oh actually I mean this
this will just go splash all over my
screen right so that is wow that's
really short why is it so short so this
to thing that someone is that's this is
an excellent file format and like on
songs as one file but m xn is actually
two files so there's this is this file
which is the definition of the graph and
there's another file that you can export
you that has the weights um okay but by
we want to ask Warren here while he's
here about configuring of GPUs I think
that was I think the main message was
it's a huge mess um so thanks Warren
okay okay so I don't understand if there
are two files what am I actually getting
here with the export strain of IMAX net
you
Sebastian left the other file the other
follow suit we had this issue where
exports didn't supports exporting to two
files except for you what did you do
so the temporary solution was that's the
zip file it makes a temporary file no
that's a really bad idea we had no other
options like we discussed this with the
input export team they mulled it over
why don't you make a zip file why don't
you make a zip file he has a phone my
spin better I think it is better so so
let's see if I look at the MX net
documentation here what it's gonna tell
me come on as a JSON file and a
corresponding dot browse file that's not
very helpful so are you telling me that
this somehow where is it even reference
does it reference the temp file here no
they're completely separate where is the
temp file filled missing because export
string just dropped it it's in the same
location as the JSON great the location
is on my screen right now and you can
also do you can specify a path and then
you can specify a place for it so with
an option those export string yeah I
don't know an export string is supposed
to do for us well let's look at the MX
net element okay this is a bit of a
screw-up if I might say so okay so this
has import elements why does it not list
export elements right because if you had
export elements you'd have a fighting
chance you could say and that's that
export and then give me the params file
or give me the the whatever this old one
was called so the options so the one way
for being explicit is with options so
you see the the options tab
so for export you can specify it we want
to put the race no this is not a good
design guys come on so the idea was that
this would be a temporary design until
export supports multiple files and
when's that gonna be because there's no
there's nothing that is driving that to
happen to my knowledge and and what
exactly is it supposed to do under those
circumstances I think the only thing it
can reasonably do because you want a
thing that you can pass around the only
thing can reasonably do is make an
archive so that's true I mean the
archive solution is a reasonable
solution I think that's what you should
implement I think what you have here is
unusable and a first approximation so
yeah so for the longer-term thing what
they wanted was I mean there's different
designs and this was this had to be
discussed as well but yes I'm either
like returning a list of like two
different paths or an association that
tells you exactly where the two things
are but that's not a good idea because
because because look in export to a file
right you can you could in principle
have a directory and it could export to
a directory and the directory could have
multiple elements in it hey Sean but in
the case of export string that's not
possible let's suppose the right way to
do it okay
look I'm taking this back a little bit
probably the right thing to do is that
export should export to a directory an
export string in that case should
produce an association with two strings
in it or multiple strings in it and
export might array the same idea
probably the correct solution and just
as a context for this as well also the
reason yeah so there's a symmetry that
for certain formats like for example
protobuf I can put formats they have
often multiple files
so we wanted to have this sort of yeah
the thing I just described is not a
totally stupid solution again let's see
where we can I asked if we can find
shadi here
okay so
all right but but basically your claim
is that if I were to take this a max net
file
I mean for example the the the
stand-alone MX net executors would be
able to ingest these this pair of MX net
files is that true or not that's true so
you can create exactly you can create an
index Nats executor with photos files
and can we do that right now
sure I mean we've is a Stack Exchange
post about this as well I mean is there
a function that we're providing that
does it and then what does it actually
do does it emit ultimately a C
executable or you know a binary a pure
executable compiled for some machine or
does it does it emit C code or what does
it actually do so there's different
versions of the next name runtime so
there's a runtime version 4 MX net
that's pure C code and you can use that
you know and whatever device to run your
export an extant net so that presumably
won't work on a GPU because it's not
creepy usually it'll only be just C hmm
so that's the option that you've got
friend X now huh and then further format
silicon so obviously there's a whole
bunch of runtimes that different
hardware platforms provide like nvidia
has a native runtime for that as well
okay so what is our plan I mean is embed
code the mechanism that we'll use to
generate those runtimes
that the right thing to be using or is
it something else
because this is a very similar problem
okay so let's let's go through the
analogous situations okay so with an API
function right we have obviously we have
something like um whatever it is and we
can say you know embed code actually I
should have given a better a better
example here if I say um this is a
terrible example of an API function if I
say X arrow integer for example and then
hash x squared ok so there's an API
function I apply it to this I get some
oh yeah right right thank you API
function so what I what I have to do
here is I have to say X arrow 78 or
something okay fine
and I can run that API function in the
cloud nor was jolly things but now I can
say embed code of that API function
comma well
say c-sharp okay
so what that's doing is it's generating
that C code there and I suppose what we
would want no it's not really correct no
it's not really correct what would
instead we want I'm sorry I'm wrong
about this okay
instead I think we want to use export
and we want to export it for as a net
model export the net model as some
format that might be called you know an
x net runtime so make more sense and
that will then generate a file that
might be the I don't know MX net C wrong
time let's say
now obviously that wouldn't have import
does that make sense and that's then
generating a file that can be
transported away and used in the you
know compiled to make a a see make a
pure runtime version of the MX net
system earlier exit Network
yes no that's a possibility yes are
there any other possibilities
well so the thing is if you are
unofficially on a certain platform so
something like iOS you don't want to run
it you don't know your own C runtime you
want to make use of that aren't and that
ships with you know and the same thing
with Windows devices where any other
device so those devices will ship with
highly efficient runtimes for particular
formats okay so then you might want to
say something like iOS runtime here
right and then we would generate
something for that I would assume or
maybe it's just MX net runtime and then
you know
target device arrow whatever I'm not
sure
or target system era whatever along like
the compiler
make sense I mean that makes some sense
yeah but we need an actual design here
to get something where you know in the
end there's going to be a file and you
take that file and you do something with
it on that device sure exactly that's
typically not be particularly smaller
and it'll be tens of megabytes typically
it's that true yeah it's the same size
is what we we store it in right but so
okay I mean is this what is this
something we could implement now to get
out the MX net C runtime version
I think it's a possibility
so there's the messiness of this whole
thing so just the network itself we can
definitely do that the messiness comes
with things like encoders decoders so
that's where yeah that's where the Onyx
thing is supposed to help maybe but it's
not you know like that it's got simple
image pre-processing but it doesn't have
I know we gave him a bunch of stuff for
doing this no not yet okay so onyx is
not a solution probably for that yet so
we need our own rapper is that rapper
compiled able with our compiler
that seems highly unlikely given that we
depend on lots of dependencies like Oh
audio encoders you know they use all
kinds of audio libraries there's the
image encoders use image libraries it's
a very messy thing I'm not sure if the
compiler has any chance well so you're
saying it's not possible to make a
standalone system will it be possible
for any of our networks or all of them I
mean like a standard image based Network
for images it's much more possible like
huge libraries you know there's probably
a lot of standardization we can have
that but for other things like audio or
for some of our tokenizer it's like
they're quite complicated and there's no
chance but yes for some networks for
sure it'll work all right so let's let's
summarize this meeting ok first point
getting
system information to know about GPUs
seemed seriously difficult first
statement
well we don't think we know I think we
don't know okay fine
so that should be taken Sushma that's
for you to the core software engineering
folk and ask that question mm-hmm okay
second thing the idea of flagging pages
with whether they have GPU you know CUDA
support you know in principle if we had
a good way to test whether something was
cheap you enabled we could at least in
product you know have some kind of
indicator on this page about GPU support
we could have a static indicator that
says if you happen to have this GPU then
it will work yeah we've talked about
similar kind of indications for this is
my list well but the static one is one I
mean it seems readily doable so what
will we say I mean we would say
something like um GPU enabled and then a
little letters underneath we would say
CUDA or something that what we would do
or what
guys I think that's for yeah all right
and what um what pages will be put this
on
basically all the neural net pages and
very little else and the various derive
no all that pages like speech recognizer
exactly
alright well Brady I think that's for
you then why don't you get that little
thing designed okay for twelve we're
saying well do we I think we care about
it for that do you think we care about I
mean like for example something like
speech recognizer does its it going to
have a target device option it does
that's what was happening here oh there
we go it does have one okay
you
okay fine going back to the system
information question the tools already
exist CUDA information does work given
that drivers are properly installed it
will do so on Windows if your drivers
are properly installed we do CUDA Q it
will give you true so all the code does
exist
the only issue over there is you might
not have proper drivers installed and
how would you know that you got a bunch
of error messages or what
sometimes it crashes Lenny do Clerq it
crashes if you don't have my god yes
it's a hard thing I learnt it yesterday
that I was working on my machine just
tell me how much of a crash is it like a
crash that crashes the operating system
as well or is it Justin who knows I mean
it's bigger thing we want to avoid is
that you have to download a gigabyte
just to learn the same thing that you
could have learned from what we've
already installed right like that's the
big duplication but that's the CUDA link
does it the correct way any other way
would be does a distribution problem the
gigabyte it could just easily be split
up if the person knows which this
assumes the thing we kept on looping
around earlier but there is no simpler
lighter weight way to tell from the
operating system whether you have a GPU
installed did you have to download these
drivers to know whether you have a GPU
which seems kind of weird to me they
might well be simpler ways to do this
but I'm just pointing out that CUDA link
requires the download of libraries that
already exist in their install so
they're only a month old is not for long
not for long that they're duplicated or
not for long I don't know we might not
be shipping
with the product because they are too
big yeah I think we shouldn't if they're
that big right because it's one point
five gigabytes at the moment just for a
max node and the reason that is is
because they are trying to support
multiple GPUs
and as long as the case well that's
crazy we should not be spending 1 point
5 gigabytes for everybody's distribution
you know for the sake of supporting you
know of having a kind of a vat of random
GPU supports agreed but for 12 I don't
think we have any choice
I think the alternatives are too
destructive and why don't we just have
it download on demand when you want it
well that's too complicated for 12 to
change what we're doing I mean unless we
want to delay the release but I don't
think we can change our mind about how
we implement better so parklets
showed me you can just download it but
the current package system are as simple
as that
why because you have to when you load
the library you've made a choice but
whether you want CPU or GPU support so
if you want to if you want GPU support
then you've got a and you want to
download that separately then you've got
to restart Mathematica in order to
achieve that that's a whole different
I mean it's achievable but it's a
variant on like I don't know is it the
case that the 1.5 gigabytes is already
being downloaded in 11 3 or not it's
part of the rule it's part of the
product in 11 3 yeah I mean I think it's
smaller in 11 3 but it's part of the
product I'm because that's you know 1.4
gigabytes is a very large lump of
downloaded stuff definitely less than 11
3 but that's because we support fewer
GPUs but to the release engineering talk
about this because maybe there's a
different solution that involves you
know so this this goes back to Alex's
days so we had a long debate about how
to do the stuff and it was decided by
release engineering that the only sane
way of doing this in the beginning would
be to have a single MX nets that we ship
but why can't you just remove the fly 20
superb on popular GPU card or something
like that that would reduce the call
immediately explain I can remain many
reasons why that's not my deal so did
you want to do we want to go into that
well I think we need to figure out how
to save the 1.5 gigabytes
George so just ballooned presumably from
something much smaller I mean one small
one only 1.5 in Windows it's one
gigabyte on it's less than a gigabytes
on Linux and Mac oh no Mac it's never
going to work right
what's that well we had a lot of
customer pushback when we deprecated GPU
support so there's a lot of external
GPUs you can get so you can run the
latest GPUs if you're having an external
GPU holder hanging out of your laptop or
something else when it's like yeah it's
a box that you power then you connect
with with the USBC but yeah this is the
wrong group we need to have this
discussion we need loose engineering
folk and I'm afraid this is a rock we
just turned over where we actually have
to figure out what's crawling around
underneath it so you know if you guys
can set up I don't need to be involved
in it in the first instance a meeting
with a release engineer and folk to try
and come up with a solution that will be
good and if necessary it may end up
being that there's you know you can
choose whether you want to download the
GPU enabled version or not I mean yeah I
mean the big obstacle to to having any
kind of download on demand things that
it's very complicated like it well fine
well maybe maybe it'll end up with two
binaries and one of them will be you
know which EP you and the other without
sure two distributions I don't know but
you got to talk to the release
engineering folks and they're gonna
freak out about this at this stage in
the release process I mean I think it's
unrealistic to to change the way we're
gonna release this this next product
I don't think we can do that for the
12th time frame well I don't think look
if it turns out we added a gigabyte to
the distribution for the sakes if not
what was it in 11 3 what was the size of
this this packing 11 3 was probably like
four megabytes smaller or something for
for Windows and for other ones it was
maybe 2 megabytes smaller all right ok
but so we already burnt this gigabyte is
what you're saying
we already basically horrifying totally
horrifying totally horrifying
um but fair enough um I still you need
to talk to the release engineering folk
about whether there might be a solution
here
okay and if we're lucky there's a
solution for 1200 otherwise there's a
solution for 12:01 or twelve point one
um okay so that was first item here um
the flagging of you know GPU enabled
functions we know that you guys can
provide a list of functions which should
have that it's basically functions that
have the target device option is that
correct I mean you're saying element
wise in principle is GPU enabled but
there's no point you mentioning that
correct there's no harm in mentioning it
well we have not going to be very useful
to mention it if if there's no way for
somebody to access it because we don't
document the target device option sure I
mean this is like one of those weird
consequences of the fact that we don't
have like we have all these layer
functions
you know like element wise layer and
threading layer and all these but a
long-term vision is that we have much
fewer of these because we just have net
function how well how wonderful that's
what we hoped we would do at the very
beginning but yes go ahead I'm sorry I
I'm instead of having a zoo of special
function layers and so on okay all right
I mean look look you can you can
complain that we didn't have this
beginning but we did have a functioning
I'm well aware
that's why yes I'm not complaining at
heart because we we knew that perfectly
well we went into this we started off
thinking you know exploring the
possibility of a very elegant functional
design and then decided that it simply
couldn't be done yet and that was the
right decision it was if we once it's
neural networks we could have just
waited five years but but the
alternative was to have the kind of
thing we have right now which is just
fine exam which will eventually become
the low-level layer that the low layer
is used in a punned way here but but I
mean the low level um you know low
levels ecosystem or something
infrastructure for the stuff we actually
build but okay so so second okay so are
we going to document target device and
all of these random layers I mean as
personally I think that's a waste like I
think we should not spend time
okay documentation of kind of gonna be
irrelevant in six months I love your
modernizing yes I am okay with that
decision
okay so we'll only document functions
that are crunchy like imagery style
speech recognizer those kinds of things
that train and sniff grass right but
those are things that already have the
the the target device option right so we
simply print
flag we put the little GPU enabled flag
on everything that has a target device
option correct what else do we need to
do here um
got this business about we've also got
this export formats thing which is
probably not a 12o story but is shortly
after 12 oh we've also got the question
of multi file export which I think we
got a reasonable design idea for which
might as well be implemented I have just
generating an association for export
string and generating a directory for
export the only thing that I can see
that's wrong
what's that shadi here yes is this
something I should know about as well
yes absolutely this is work for your
team okay the the okay the issue is Amex
net export really deals with generating
two files right and some total hacker
Lola solution was made for this that
involves writing one file into a temp
directory yep horrifying do we have many
yeah do we have other formats that have
export that export to multiple files
no let's just never come up in any other
case for import of protobufs we did
discuss the similar thing so we were
going to look into in general
Association support both in import and
export where you give keys to individual
file types and then the pack to that
file I think there needs to be some
framework level update that we can
support these guys so what I'm
suggesting then shadi is that that we
basically have normally on export it
would write a directory okay we might
have an option to write a zip file
instead I see okay now the only issue
with that is if you if you export and
then you want to delete what you export
it and you say delete file on the
directory does it work so I'm curious
I'm curious like you say that the normal
things to export to directory I haven't
seen that before is that something that
exists no no I'm not saying it's a
normal thing I'm suggesting that's what
we plan to do
in the future I think that should be one
of the modes alternatively I don't know
you're suggesting that maybe the good
defaults right Steven yes and then the
alternative will be a zip file how about
just at the working directory just the
two files
that should as well be a mode maybe
scible though that violates another
principle of export which is that the
name of the exported that there is a no
one well ok fair enough that's a
reasonable mode also I mean what is it
return export always return something
that is the name of a file it returns
the name of file so it would have to
return an association which has which
would also be what it could be used for
input exact exact the file type error
the name of the file right that's an
important principle to maintain that
kind of round-trip ability right ok then
the other case is export string and
export byte array which I claim should
return a an association
right like it could say / am I row and
then the string for the parameter file
JSON arrow and then the string for the
JSON file mm-hmm um same for save the
battery is presuming exactly and in
terms of import string import byte array
work just exactly the same way because
otherwise it can't eat an association I
mean that would be it's only it's only
way of consuming an association will be
look the mechanism like this right okay
well right I think we have a plan there
anything else we need to cover in this
meeting sounds good okay Oh
the other thing that came out of this is
the need for workflow documentation for
the absolute horror of setting up GPUs
it's not that I mean it's not really not
that bad like I mean we do offer a
better experience with using GPUs than
basically any other any other frameworks
I don't know if absolute horror is quite
the right phraseology to use what he's
saying is like that you know the device
drivers and things and you have like 10
different brands of Linux and whatnot it
is a horror I mean it seems we do say
that you're using XYZ device driver and
you should be a deceide device driver
that is given messages those messages we
provide yes okay so actually there's
another piece sushma this is for you the
compatibility page needs to be spruced
up to describe whatever it is we think
we're I mean just like you have that
list of in target device you have that
list that's the list from target device
should make its way on to the
compatibility page makes sense yep yes
um okay okay
um all right anything else here
nope okay thanks all thanks to folks on
the livestream yeah it was a bit of a
horrifying discussion here um and Oh
yes yes I'm I been on our live stream is
complaining that 1.4 gigabytes is huge
yes you are right and we need to not be
downloading that for everybody for the
you know for the sake of the the the
microscopic fraction of people on a Mac
you know with their downloading it for
their laptop and and you know most
people don't have a a separate you know
GPU that's hanging off there all right
good stuff thank you all um and yeah
great okay see you later bye-bye